[Music]
41 years have passed since an
archaeology professor an adventurer set
out in search of the ark of the covenant
and engaged in a race with the nazis we
are of course talking about none other
than dr henry walton jones jr or better
known as indiana jones played by
harrison ford now ford and his character
have aged quite a bit but that does not
stop him from playing the role of the
treasure hunter again and again next
year it will be that time once more as
the fifth film is scheduled to be
released in theaters since not much is
known about the title yet naturally we
wonder what kind of treasure will he be
hunting this time who will be his
antagonist and of course in which period
of time will the whole story take place
now there are already all kinds of
rumors to save you from having to spend
hours on the web looking for information
we have summarized all the facts about
the cast the production and the plot for
you here in this video
let's get to the cast a few familiar
faces have already been confirmed
however we can only speculate about
their roles since there is neither a
trailer nor any other information so far
of course the most important person in
the film is indiana indie jones who is
played by harrison ford after playing
the smuggler han solo in star wars this
was ford's second major role under
george lucas indiana jones earned his
phd in archaeology at the university of
chicago where he also lectured as a
professor but as everyone knows his
great love was treasure hunting and
above all the mission to bring the
treasures to the museum his most
frequent adversaries in this were the
nazis he already had to face them in two
out of four movies the iconic traits of
the adventurer with a doctorate are
clearly the fedora hat his whip and his
panicked fear of snakes whereas indy
went on a treasure hunt in the first
three parts before the second world war
in indiana jones and the kingdom of the
crystal skull he found himself in the
cold war with the soviet union
the first new addition to the cast is
phoebe waller bridge this could be one
of the 42 year old actress and
screenwriter's first major roles in a
hollywood movie of this format she
already worked with ford in the star
wars sequel solo a star wars story we
could imagine her being the woman at
indy's side in the film after all
similar to james bond he always has
female support meanwhile the antagonist
is already known he'll be played by mads
mikkelsen it was just this year that
mikkelsen slipped in the role of
grindelwald in fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore and he's already
shown in older productions that he is
capable of playing the role of the
villain perfectly with a star like
mikkelsen as the opponent we are already
looking forward to the hunt for whatever
treasure a german actor also gets to
take part in the film thomas crutchman
the former swimmer was last seen in the
second season of the netflix series
biohackers he is not a complete unknown
in hollywood though having already
started movies such as peter jackson's
king kong resident evil apocalypse and
avengers age of ultron what role he will
play in indiana jones 5 is not yet clear
however since there are already photos
of nazi uniforms on the set it is
reasonable to assume that he will end up
wearing one boyd holbrook is also one of
the new guys in the franchise the u.s
actor and model was last seen as the
corinthian in the series sandman he
previously had bigger roles in logan in
which he played the antagonist and the
predator however we still have no idea
whether he'll be competing against the
protagonist as usual or whether he will
devote himself to being the good guy
this time around and with charnette
renee wilson the movie gets a new face
that is still almost unheard of in
hollywood apart from a supporting role
in black panther the 32 year old actress
has not had any major roles yet by
contrast toby jones is very well known
the british starred in all sorts of big
movies whether it's irwin sola in the
mcu or sir william ingram in the
electrical life of lewis wayne jones
will no doubt be an asset to the film as
we have already seen in captain america
the first avenger the part of a nazi mad
scientist suits him well so maybe we get
to fill that role again now but besides
ford mickelson and jones another
hollywood star is joining the cast
antonio banderas will also assume a role
in the film along with ford banderas is
also somewhat aging at the age of 62 yet
that does not prevent him from immersing
himself once again in a real adventure
after all the spaniard is well versed as
a treasure hunter his most recent film
appearance was as santiago moncada in
the video game adaptation uncharted
actually in the fourth part it was
teased as a big story where things are
headed indy is the father of young
daredevil henry mutt williams embodied
by shia labeouf his mother was none
other than marion williams known to most
as marion ravenwood from raiders of the
lost ark but it was not only the movie
the kingdom of the crystal skull that
flopped with fans the fact that the buff
was supposed to take over from harrison
ford at some point also upset the fans
more than they were able to come to
terms with the idea thus the role was
cancelled and to this day neither leboff
nor karen allen appear in the casting
lists rumor has it the character of the
sun may have made it back regardless for
instance residents of the filming
locations report they have seen footage
of a stunt double riding a horse closely
followed by a boy with grease back hair
on a motorcycle this already resembles
very much the young le buff from the
fourth part logically it would also make
sense when you consider the role of
indiana jones india is admittedly not
always the friendliest of contemporaries
but since he himself was often left
alone by his father we hardly believed
that he would abandon his own son
shortly after meeting
him after the moderate success and
rather poor reviews of the kingdom of
the crystal skull the idea of a fifth
part of indiana jones was initially
abandoned it was not until the disney
takeover in 2013 that the subject was
brought up again in 2015 lucasfilm
president kathleen kennedy announced
that another film was being planned
however not only that two more films are
also be released in the future as
director it was possible just like in
the four previous films to engage steven
spielberg at first however he resigned
and justified his departure by saying
that he wanted to make way for a new
generation that would bring its
perspective to the story he has been
replaced by 58 year old james mangold
who among other projects direct the last
two wolverine movies spielberg however
did not want to drop out of the project
altogether along with kathleen kennedy
and frank marshall he is responsible for
the production of the film the film's
screenplay was already completed in
september 2017 but not me with much
approval from the people in charge thus
david kepp was substituted into
screenwriter and replaced by john kasdan
the latter already wrote the script for
solo a star wars story together with his
father this led to the actual release
date of june 2020 having to be pushed
back after many postponements and the
events of the past few years filming was
finally set to begin in june 2021 the
film was shot at pinewood studios near
london and in sicily although a first
trailer for the movie is not yet
available an image has already been
published it shows indiana jones himself
walking across a bridge in a dark cave
in dim light at first glance there is
hardly any difference to earlier films
even though harrison ford and thus his
character indiana jones have aged
noticeably for harrison ford it is
definitely his last appearance in his
cult role as the treasure hunter john
williams will likewise be involved in a
project for the last time he has once
again been responsible for the musical
accompaniment to the spectacle but would
like to take his well-deserved
retirement at the age of 90 the movie is
scheduled to be released on june 30th
2023 and we are confident no changes
will be made to this date
that leaves one big question in which
setting is the adventure taking place
after the last part of the series was
set in the 50s this time will probably
be in the 60s the focus is on the
competition for the moon landing between
the us and the soviet union for this
nasa has to rely on an ex-nazi scientist
who however also pursues his own goals
as mentioned previously he is played by
mads mikkelsen but according to insiders
it will not stop at a simple landing on
the moon indiana jones 5 is also
supposed to include time travel this is
of course neither confirmed nor denied
so far one clue is that harrison ford
was seen with dots on his face during
filming these are used for example to
rejuvenate a character in
post-production how this is supposed to
fit into the classic treasure hunt
concept is yet to be seen indeed time
must somehow be found in the storyline
to bring in a successor for the next two
films mikkelsen is certainly raving
about ford in the movie telling
reporters indy 5 will be a real old
school indie film and harrison ford is
out of this world i hope i'll be as fit
when i'm 80. thus we can look forward to
great things
and that was all the information that is
currently available about indiana jones
5. what are you most looking forward to
in the film or would you like to see a
former companion of indy that has not
been confirmed yet let us know in the
comments
[Music]
you